Smart Cities is basically information
and communications technology
applied to traffic or public
safety or water and sewer.
Technology can bring a lot of solutions
to the challenges that cities face.
And that gets us smart.
But you gotta take
it another step.
When you define traffic
as automobiles,
buses, bikes, pedestrians,
folks who have to use a wheelchair
to get around their city.
Project by project it's improving
the quality of life for everybody.
By making traffic
lights smarter,
that actually monitor the traffic build
up in each direction in real time
and then turn green the direction where
the traffic build up is very high,
and then also communicate with
subsequent traffic lights
saying that I am sending
traffic your way
so we can actually coordinate the traffic
flow across the city dynamically,
making decisions every
couple of seconds.
You can actually
monitor air pollution
and basically bring in policies and
solutions to actually reduce pollution.
There'll be fewer automotive
accidents, injuries and fatalities.
Traffic will flow smoother.
So a mother taking her child to school
will actually get there on time.
So we at CMU as academics want to
basically create this body of knowledge,
technologies,
policies and solutions
which get deployed
in real cities,
in real metropolitan regions
that over time basically
becomes bedrock
on which other cities
and societies can build up on.
By being a university that wrestles
with the real world problems,
brings its research and development
capabilities to bear on those problems
and partners with, whether it's cities
or corporations, other countries,
we multiple the total impact
on a global population.